bonjour on est ravis de vous accueillir
merci d'être là Mélanie au frais vous
êtes la réalisatrice de ce film Lionel
Abelanski bonjour vous êtes l'acteur
l'adjoint du maire on va en parler dans
quelques instants bon le film est sorti
le 1er mars 5 cartons on peut le dire on
peut dire ça comme ça
il y a quoi super content plus de 800000
entrées je crois c'est ça c'est une
surprise pour vous Mélanie je sais pas
si c'est une surprise en tout cas on a
travaillé on a fait des mois et des mois
tournés pour aller présenter le film un
peu partout en France donc on est
content surtout que le que le public se
retrouve et se l'approprie c'est c'est
une très belle petite victoire ouais
quels sont les retours les plus
surprenants que vous avez eu donc ce que
je voudrais juste ajouter c'est que
Mélanie elle a fait des mois de tourner
mais presque toute seule regarde
elle est vraiment allée dans des
villages où il y a pas de culture il y a
pas de cinéma où elle a amené amené le
film et ça et ça a été un engagement
incroyable elle a été AD
[Musique]
mais pourquoi on rouvre pas le bistrot
je crois qu'on détient le record
départemental de retraite permis par
habitant
tu l'as toujours ta tireuse
qu'est-ce que je vois madame le Maire
qui est enterré à côté de mont-de-marcel
cette garce de Georgette Moreau et alors
mais elle a toujours tourné autour de
mon mari
bordel il y a un trou comme ça dans la
chaussée on attend son tour
j'ai failli esclater ma bagnole il faut
me réparer ça allez on range les vélos
mais qu'est-ce que vous faites là je
vais apprendre
pourquoi tu sais pas lire c'est jamais
rentré dans ma tête et puis après j'ai
oublié
[Musique]
ça fait oh ben non ça fait oh
tu déconnes
tu es trop gentille
[Musique]
ça tireuse allez oh allez les gars salut
ça va
dans le feu de la jeunesse
nestlés et l'amour fait des prouesses
vous avez vu ma dictée presque sans
faute juste
[Musique]
la cigarette
[Rires]
Michel Blanc dans ce film également
c'est un film politique vous parlez d'un
film politique engagé non
pas de faire un film politique ni
militant après on me demande souvent
quel est le message aussi que que je
souhaite que que j'ai voulu en effet
mettre en avant je pense que c'est
important de faire des choses ensemble
je pense que voilà dans nos petits
villages faut continuer à se battre pour
que pour qu'il se passe des choses et ça
passe par le lien social et je pense que
tant que les gens continueront à se voir
continueront à échanger continueront à
voilà à avoir des projets alors il y
aura ce lien il se passera plein de
choses il y aura de l'action oui c'est
ça c'est que même la tonalité
intéressante ça fait pas de misérabilité
il y a une sorte d'enthousiasme c'est
aussi pour ça que ça marche Lionel ce
film moi je crois c'est parce que ça
touche profondément les gens mais je
pense que Mélanie elle dit qu'elle fait
pas de films politiques mais c'est
le film sont politiques son premier film
qui s'appelait Roxane c'est ça parlait
aussi des exploitants agricoles qui
avaient du Cavé du mal et voilà sa façon
d'en parler c'est la comédie et je crois
que c'est ce qui touche les gens c'est à
dire on est elle va pas
dire que le drame c'est du pathos mais
elle va pas dans le pathos elle essaie
de voilà de rendre
vrai humain et beau ces gens et de et
voilà les sublime et leur donne
une motivation et pourtant le film se
déroule dans un village et kergwen qui
est pas un village facile c'est quoi
c'est le symbole c'est un village qui
est un peu le le symbole de la France
dit périphérique la France peut être des
gilets jaunes on peut le résumer comme
ça ou c'est un peu trop schématique non
enfin je pense que c'est surtout c'est
la c'est les personnages de Alice les
personnages de emis sont des personnages
qui voilà la mère Alice qui a la foi
l'institutrice en même temps le la mère
de son village elle est elle est je
pense
personnage qui a l'image de notre
société de ce de ces personnes qui sont
complètement dévouées à leur fonction
des voix à leur administrer et qui font
partie des gens qui ont envie de changer
les choses et donc j'ai pas envie
forcément de parler de deux de gilets
jaunes c'était pas le forcément le
souhait mais c'était un une vraie envie
en fait que les gens s'identifient à
elle c'est vrai que aujourd'hui aussi un
personnage comme Alice c'était un vrai
souhait de montrer une femme qui soit
indépendante qui soit forte qui soit
aussi célibataire qui est des des envies
et des objectifs qui soient pas
forcément
voilà
j'allais dire un peu commun de ce qu'on
peut voir dans les films elle est pas
dans une une quête amoureuse elle est
plutôt dans une quête de soi et c'est
des je pense que c'est des
problématiques qui nous parlent
aujourd'hui donc les personnages d'Alice
et puis il y a le personnage
Lionel Saturn inquiet Saturnin qui est
dévoué à
oui donc à son maire à son maireux à sa
mère est sa mère
un ami fidèle qui lui est voué vraiment
qui lui doit énormément alors c'est pas
vraiment raconté mais nous on s'était
raconté des
Mélanie surtout qui m'a raconté un peu
le background de ce personnage et qui
est prêt voilà qui est prêt qui a des
idées un petit peu il va un peu trop
loin
c'est un peu un rêveur un idéaliste il
est un peu trop ambitieux pour pour son
visage pour son village quoi il était un
peu il a des visées un peu démesurées il
en faut du rêve en politique on peut
encore rêver en politique c'est ça c'est
que Saturnin il propose de créer une
sorte de Silicon Valley dans ce dans ce
village et on lui dit oui mais il manque
il vous manque la fibre quoi c'est ça
mais ce qui est très drôle c'est que les
fraises en fait de Lionel elles sont
tirées de de de vraies rencontres que
j'ai eu avec des élus parce que j'ai
voilà pour écrire le film que j'ai
co-écrit avec Michael souhaiter mon
coeur mais avant moi je suis vraiment ce
travail de terrain où j'ai été passée du
temps avec une vingtaine de mères
partout en France le journalistique
exactement il y a un travail presque
journalistique parce que je voulais
surtout pas voilà fausser le être être
fausse et être très juste très sincère
et donc il y a beaucoup de phrases en
fait qui sont tirées du du véhicule des
phrases que j'ai vraiment entendu la
scène à la Communauté de Communes c'est
vraiment des phrases que j'ai notées mot
pour mot et pareil aussi j'ai rencontré
un maire d'un petit village et qui était
un rêveur incroyable et qui lui il avait
des idées folles il était prêt à
déplacer des montagnes et il disait
ouais en fait je veux que mon village
soit la prochaine Silicon Valley parce
que je suis dans une vallée donc il
manque juste la fibre mais quand la
fibre sera là je le ferai ce sera mieux
ce sera mieux et c'est ça qui est super
alors l'intrigue tourne autour de la
boulangerie du village qu'il faut
réhabiliter on va revoir un petit
extrait de votre film
j'ai une bonne nouvelle
je me suis rangé avec la boulangerie de
boire avec on peut vendre leur pain ici
voilà
[Applaudissements]
je conteste pas Alice mais pourquoi on
rouvre pas le Bistrot Le Bistrot lui le
convivialité nouvelle Agora moderne là
où on discute des problèmes de la cité
c'est vrai qu'on y réfléchissant c'est
vrai qu'on a réfléchissant je crois
qu'on détient le record départemental de
retraite permis par habitant non
on va plutôt se concentrer sur le pain
ça représente quoi une boulangerie dans
un village comme kaguel c'est
indispensable c'est vrai que en faisant
vraiment ce travail de terrain je me
suis rendu compte que la perte en fait
des commerces c'est le début
malheureusement de de la descente
aux enfers j'allais dire c'est un peu
exagéré mais c'est c'est les prémices en
tout cas de de de difficultés que va
vivre le village parce que un commerce
une boulangerie une boucherie c'est là
où les gens se voient se retrouvent et
c'est vraiment un endroit qui est voilà
qui essentiel pour le lien pour le lien
social il y a plus de bistrot il y a
plus de coiffeurs il y a plus de docteur
c'est un des personnages du film qui dit
ça à Alice la mer mais il reste beaucoup
de relations et de chaleur humaine c'est
aussi ça qu'il fallait montrer vous en
parliez un peu tout à l'heure mais c'est
aussi ça qui ressort du film Lionel et
puis c'est un peu ce qu'on a ressenti
nous c'est à dire que au moment du
tournage parce que bon moi je suis
vraiment parisien je suis né à Paris
j'ai des souvenirs de de province qui
sont que des voyages ou des souvenirs
d'enfants on va vraiment des souvenirs
de vacances ou heure de travail mais
aujourd'hui mais on sent on sent qu'il y
a une qui a une demande qu'il y a que
que vraiment qu'un manque moi j'ai
maintenant j'ai un peu plus de 50 ans
donc j'ai vécu j'ai vécu j'ai connu ces
villages avec avec un café avec une
boucherie avec une boulangerie et ce qui
est très très rare aujourd'hui et ce qui
était fou c'est que dans le petit
village où on tournait qui s'appelle le
Juke il y a il y a quelques il y avait
11 bistrots et
bon maintenant grâce au film il y en a
un qui va se couvrir parce que le film a
eu un effet ouais ça a été marrant le
fait dans le film ce que vous voyez on
le voit dans la bande-annonce il y a une
mairie mais c'était un bâtiment qui
essaie voilà
laissé son projet depuis plusieurs
années et puis le fait que il y a eu un
j'allais dire un petit buzz médiatique
avec la présence de Lionel de Michel de
Julia et bah le jus qui a fait beaucoup
parler de lui dans la vallée et donc et
donc ce fameux bâtiment qui était un
petit peu laissé son projet depuis
plusieurs années va redevenir un bar
nouvelle juste pour revenir sur sur le
maire sur Alice qui est vraiment le
personnage principal le principal le
personnage fort de votre film elle se
change en psychologue de couple elle
fait un peu tous les métiers c'est ça
qui est aussi génial dans ce film c'est
aussi un moyen de tirer la sonnette
d'alarme de dire vous voyez le rôle de
mère aujourd'hui est en danger il y a
des risques si on connaît on connaît les
risques avec les violences mais il faut
aider ces mères il faut vraiment il faut
les écouter faut les écouter il faut les
entendre et c'est vrai que au début j'y
croyais pas l'anecdote de de des
confessions intimes du couple sur la
vingtaine de mères avec qui j'ai passé
du temps il y en a eu 9 qui m'ont
raconté cette histoire expliquez-nous en
fait c'est donc c'est un c'est un
village qui voilà qui vient raconter
leur petit leur petit problème intime et
je lui ai Piaton donc voilà qui joue le
rôle d'Alice c'est un peu décontenancé
face à face à ces confessions et en fait
quand on en parle aussi avec les mères
les élus ils nous explique il nous
disent mais oui mais comme il y a plus
de docteur comme il y a plus de curé les
gens en fait ils viennent nous voir pour
nous parler de tout ça donc c'est là où
on se rend compte vraiment de la place
du rôle du maire qui est comme voilà le
clocher sur la place du village c'est
c'est une c'est une c'est vraiment une
écoute c'est vraiment une oreille et que
et qui sont indispensables aujourd'hui
c'est aussi un moyen de dire bon il y a
des difficultés mais même aussi c'est
quand même un job une fonction qui est
intéressante parce qu'on est au contact
finalement de ces administrés Lionel
joint comment vous avez vécu pour que
l'engagement il est vraiment au
quotidien c'est quasiment 24 heures sur
24 c'est-à-dire c'est
et c'est concret c'est pas dans voilà
dans la théorie c'est vraiment
en lien vraiment avec les gens c'est
aussi apporter d'engueulade c'est à dire
qu'on vient enfin on est confronté
vraiment à la violence aussi des
rapports sociaux dans ces communes qui
sont délaissés disons-le oui et puis
c'est vrai que si dans les petites
victoires on montre que tout se passe
pas non plus toujours bien il y a des
personnes avec qui on s'entend ou avec
qui on s'entend moins ça aurait été faux
de de pas raconter ses rapports là et
pour rebondir sur ce que vous disiez
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui en fait un
maire c'est tout c'est que c'est à la
fois un technicien de voirie un
technicien EDF un psychologue c'est que
ce log et c'est beaucoup plus que et en
plus il
c'est beaucoup plus qu'une fonction
c'est un dévouement et c'est ça aussi
que qu'on a voulu mettre à l'honneur
c'est de parler de ces héros du
quotidien qui se pensent ordinaire alors
que je pense qu'ils sont extraordinaires
par par leur action vous avez montré le
film à des élus vous avez eu des retours
alors on a même fait j'allais dire mieux
c'est que au tout début en fait de la de
la tournée on l'a présenté à la MF donc
à l'assemblée des mères euro de France
donc autant vous dire que j'étais quand
même pas mal stressé donc il y avait
presque 200 m donc le ruraux dans la
salle et ça a été super parce que donc
la scène de la Communauté de Communes
n'a jamais autant ri il y a jamais
autant de rire dessus mais c'était super
parce que les gens se sont vraiment
retrouvés en fait et je crois qu'ils
étaient émus qu'on mettrait en lumière
un petit peu ce qui
leur fonction et puis dans ce film il y
a cette question posée par Michel Blanc
il va où le pognon de nos impôts c'est
la question qu'il pose quand il débarque
dans l'école il a 65 ans et veut tout
reprendre à zéro on va revoir un petit
extrait de votre film
je suis toujours là et là et ben il y a
ton père
[Musique]
il va où le pognon dans un pot mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites là
[Applaudissements]
c'est-à-dire
apprendre c'est ici que ça a merdé c'est
ici que ça repartira
oui non mais non non ça va pas être
possible je peux pas vous garder dans ma
classe monsieur mais non pourquoi vous
pouvez pas pourquoi parce que
déjà la loi la loi et puis aussi parce
que vous voyez mon mon plus vieil élève
ici il a 11 ans
aujourd'hui il a 65 allez
Michel Blanc
dans ce film il joue ainsi un rôle un
rôle assez unique qui représente quelque
chose aussi peut-être dans ces villages
lyonnais bah oui évidemment que Émile en
fait il incarne aussi une certaine forme
de solitude ce genre de personne qui vit
un petit peu exclu en
antarctie un petit peu dans qui vit dans
sa bulle on s'entraîne bien mon
périmètre grande phrase dans ce film
c'est une manière de dire voilà qu'il
est un peu assigné à résidence il peut
pas aller de son village il voit pas
tellement ce qui se passe au-delà de ce
village et puis là ça c'est encore plus
réduit parce que son histoire donc on
peut on peut le dire c'est
avec son frère son frère et son frère
est décédé et dans le village on se rend
compte qu'il est très qui s'est ni lire
ni écrire et de lui décide de retourner
à l'école et c'est
la seule solution pour survivre en fait
c'est parce que
l'histoire de ce périmètre c'est à dire
qu'il ne peut pas sortir parce que sinon
il est perdu il est perdu dans il est
perdu dans le monde et donc c'est le
voilà le rapport de ces deux personnages
qui est formidablement bien décrit et
qui est très touchant et qui est super
bon bien interprété par Michel Blanc la
relation entre Michel Blanc et la mère
aussi quelque chose d'assez assez unique
je pense vous l'avez constaté aussi sur
le terrain ou c'est quelque chose un peu
vous avez rajouté comme ça pour le film
c'est-à-dire que vous avez fait votre
enquête journalistique et cette relation
existe dans les dans les faits sur le
ça amène de la vie ça amène une une
présence la présence des enfants
symbolise aussi l'avenir il y a quelque
chose de très fort par la présence des
enfants dans une dans une dans un
village
ça représente l'avenir ouais les petites
victoires c'est le nom du film c'est
quoi les petites victoires pourquoi les
petites victoires pourquoi les petites
victoires merci de poser cette question
parce que comme je vous le disais voilà
c'était j'ai fait un gros travail de
terrain il y a un maire qui m'a vraiment
chamboulé qui était un merde un petit
village en centre Bretagne et ce
monsieur d'ailleurs a été très fatigué
et n'allait pas repartir pour un nouveau
mandat je l'ai rencontré en 2019 parce
qu'il était voilà agriculteur de vaches
laitières en même temps que d'être mère
et ce monsieur en fait tous les mois il
perdait de l'argent à faire à être
maître à être mère et à être agriculteur
donc autant vous dire que voilà c'était
compliqué et qu'il allait pas repartir
pour pour un nouveau un nouveau mandat
et je lui ai demandé qu'est-ce que tu as
retenu en fait de cette de cette
expérience et il m'a répondu cette
phrase il m'a dit bah tu vois je suis
arrivée avec l'envie de révolutionner la
vie de mon village je suis arrivé avec
plein d'espoir et j'ai appris une chose
c'est que je repars avec ce qu'il y a de
plus beau c'est mes petites victoires
viennent peut-être du terrain aussi de
vraiment de la base elle viendra pas
forcément Paris ou du gouvernement ou de
l'état de manière générale qui sont plus
politiques hein
c'est fou je peux ça fait quand il y a
eu justement tout ce mouvement des
gilets jaunes les mères étaient les
premières ressentir cette détresse et
c'est vrai que c'est c'est fou la
connaissance que peut avoir un maire
face à son village face à ses
administrés il y avait un pareil une une
élue qui m'avait dit cette phrase cette
phrase que pendant le covid elle pouvait
dire le contenu des frigos de chacun de
ces administrés je trouve que c'est très
fort comme comme phrase et il y avait
c'était un village de 100 habitants et
donc elle était vraiment cette cette
personne qui allait qui allait aider et
qui connaissait tellement bien les
Stéphanie d'ailleurs on le il y a une
petite scène dans les petites victoires
on voit Alice qui se charge de de faire
les courses pour Marie-Pierre Casey
c'est un petit clin d'oeil à ça mais
mais oui je trouve que c'est incroyable
c'est ce dévouement que que font que ces
personnes font en fait pour leur pour
leur village Lionel le je vous donne le
mot de la fin les petites victoires
qu'est-ce que c'est pour vous nous je
pense que notre une victoire c'est
d'avoir je pense réussir à raconter
cette histoire et que et que ça aille
toucher les gens c'est à dire que le
film est très très belle vie et au-delà
de nos espérances je pense et que ça va
et que ça continue et
j'espère que ça s'arrêtera jamais on
vous le souhaite en tout cas merci à
tous les deux je rappelle donc le titre
du film Les petites victoires si vous ne
l'avez pas encore vu courez dans les
salles ce week-end de Pâques vous allez
vous régaler vous allez aussi beaucoup
apprendre sur la situation de de ces
villages que vous racontez très bien
dans ce film merci à tous d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation